et voilà on ouvre le casque ça va dans
sa jeunesse chers amis bonjour 20e à
monsieur du snav voilà une surprise
bonjour mon cher comment allez-vous très
bio chers amis j'ai passé hier une
soirée divine avec des gens d'une
qualité intellectuelle tout à fait
remarquable est que fit vous au cours de
cette soirée
j'ai lu quelques-uns de mes poèmes une
autre succès mon ami j'aurais voulu que
vous soyez là les dames ne pouvait
retenir leurs larmes tellement elle
était vous avez trouvé le mot juste une
charge lui c'était grandiose à monsieur
l'islande que fidji d'autres cours de
cette grande soirée allemand par les
palmes le fait d'y repenser j'ai le
coeur qui défaillent la charmante
demoiselle coloquintes de tous nous a
interprété 10 ont essayé je leur ai pas
prêté en s'accompagnant elle même au
piano une charmante une mélodie
hautement philosophique
intitulé assez les oiseaux faisaient
leur nid avec du béton on aurait du
petit bois pour l'hiver les spas
ravissant et c'est si bouleversement
mais dites moi monsieur du snav vous
avez dû vous coucher très tard à mon
cher ami alors je viens juste de me
lever
quel dommage pour vous nous au contraire
nous avons profité d'une merveilleuse
journée et avec le chant des petits
oiseaux qui gens qui m'emmenait reculer
toutes les brandit du jardin pour faire
leur nid c'est un avantage auquel je
n'ai pas pensé
il faudra qu'un conseil à cette
charmante colloque est de tout d'abord
donné son idée denis en béton monsieur
19 vous voulez quelque chose à boire non
va décidément très gentil merci serge
july je viens seulement par kasimi et
des moyens optimaux pour me donner
rendez vous
on n'avait pas vu et ben non justement à
nos s'il avait promis d'être là et nous
attendons en vain ah bah tiens justement
georges collective bonjour casimiro jour
sans que sinon tu m'as l'air depuis leur
succès on est toujours de bonne humeur
quand on va faire une bonne action
ça c'est très vrai et quelle est cette
belle action eh bien j'ai décidé de vous
faire un cadeau à tous les trois parce
que vous êtes tellement gentil avec moi
mais c'est qu'on t'aime beaucoup casimir
le faisons là rien d'extraordinaire mais
si si si j'y tiens beaucoup
et puis ça me fait tellement plaisir
mais dis-moi casimir pourquoi
aujourd'hui sans aucune raison a si
justement il y a une très bonne raison
laquelle eh bien j'ai tout rangé chez
moi et j'ai retrouvé les objets dont je
ne savais pas quoi faire alors au lieu
de les jeter à la poubelle
j'ai pensé vous les données des
appareils destinés à être jetés aux
ordures
bah tu vois j'attendais mieux mener mes
murs à casimir tu si ce prénom nous
offrir des objets que tu voulais mettre
à la poubelle mais ouais non non non mon
voeu que du mur quand on veut faire un
cadeau on off c'est pas moi d des jolies
choses qu'on aimerait bien garder pour
soi et pas de vieux objets tout casser
dont on veut plus on fera
tu crois bon j'en suis sûr la compagnie
qui est beau temps aujourd'hui par un
bon jour exact air rien pour vous
attendez attendez une minute
oui pigeon partie par là ça ne vous
ennuierez pas de jeter ça en passant
dans la poubelle on sur casimir
merci de casimir qu'est-ce que du feu
qu'est ce qu'on fait voilà j'adore cette
manne et tous les objets auxquels je
tiens le plus alors j'ai décidé de vous
en donner à chacun bon alors ça c'est
vraiment trop gentil kazimi
c'est un grand père je suis fier d'être
ton ami il ya une jolie guitare avec
avec son manche j'ai aussi un très beau
plat en porcelaine de limoges une
chambre à air
c'est délicieux avec de la crème
chantilly et puis j'ai s'il approuve une
très belle pour y regarder c'est beau
hein c'est pas pour dire mais le choix
va être difficile je me demande si nous
avons le droit de le priver de ces
objets préférés
qu'est-ce que ça devait être dans
l'autre sac alors lesquels voulez-vous
et bien écoute casimir ce sont des
objets préférés je crois qu'on n'a pas
le droit de te prives non non non ça on
n'a pas le droit
alors tu les gardes mais merci quand
même c'est surtout la tension qui compte
sans regarder ce qu'ils avaient dans le
sac je vais donner un chiffonnier
si vous aviez entendu ses cris de joie
dans le sacré un réveil tout neuf
une sculpture moderne de toute beauté
est une belle langue bouchard et casimir
casimir ce sont les objets que tu
voulais nous donner au lieu de les jeter
ouais et alors
enfin on aurait dû regarder avant de
dire non on sculpture moderne c'est
vraiment trop bête
tél
[Musique]